I think it's really important for us who
are fans of the open Internet to think
about what language what structures what
ways of talking about why we care about
the Internet we need to use so that
we're not just talking to one another in
holding hands and singing Kumbaya
right
I think it was almost 20 years ago 1997
that a bunch of nerds got into a room
and and created this crazy saying this
open source browser called Firefox which
is was a signal event I think in the in
the history of the web as more and more
people come online that event in 1997
means less and less to the 15 year old
kid and be Neil Del Mar or the the 42
year old farmer coming on going on the
internet for the first time in
Mozambique and and the challenge we've
put forth for the pant for the next
group that's going to be talking is is
how do we do that how do we take these
values and approaches in frame of the
open web that we all care and value so
much how do we transfer that to to the
three billion people on the planet who
will be coming on the web over the next
couple of years so I am going to hand it
off to this three this esteemed group of
folks who have all actually as I think
about it they've all been well I'm a
sort of night news night foundation
family members in different ways Seamus
Kraft the executive founding executive
director the open gov foundation mark
sermon the executive director of Mozilla
Foundation Elise who technology and
culture reporter for NPR all have been
great partners and advisors to us at
night foundation so I'm excited to hear
what they come up with at least I'll
hand it over to you because you're in
charge
[Music]
thanks everybody for joining us
post-lunch we want to make this a
conversation and not a panel so that all
of you all can get involved and to sort
of frame the conversation and as John
set this up really well this is kind of
the heart of the economy going forward
this issue is also newsy this summer and
and it's the theme of this conference
it's why we're meeting so it's really
exciting that we get to talk about this
and to sort of frame his thoughts on
this going forward
mark has prepared a few short slides to
get us in the right mindset and so that
we can watch parts of the movie so we're
gonna start with mark and then post mark
we'll talk a little bit about sheamus's
background and how we got here so mark
over to you my slides up awesome so I'm
gonna talk about the open Internet a
little bit but first I need to air a
little bit of dirty laundry this is the
band mark sermon grade 11 yearbook
picture
and you know I've put this up there I
lived a very small town in Northern
Ontario but 10,000 people mill town and
I put this out
not because I want sympathy for having
been the one punk rock kid in Kenora
Ontario but because as I think about the
internet everyday in my work a lot comes
from that moment in my life that it was
so exciting I was so drawn in by the
idea that anybody anybody could pick up
a guitar write a song anybody could get
a tascam four-track cassette recorder
and record an album anybody like me
could get a pair of scissors some glue
and a photocopier and make a magazine
and well today that just seems
absolutely trivial at the time that was
just revolutionary punk was a
revolutionary movement a movement of
resistance against a monoculture
monocultural of culture and the the
thing that really has stayed with me
from that time although I've still has
balls the other thing that has stayed
with me other than the haircut is this
DIY ethos that was absolutely central to
what punk rock was and I think came into
the hearts and minds of tens of millions
of people around the world and that
ethos still guides me every day and in
leadership and parenting and whatever I
do and I think that ethos really has
infused itself in ways that now are the
maker movement or really a lot about
what the web is and that's actually the
kind of thing to John's point we need to
think about with the web and the open
web I think that we haven't quite done
and in fact are in danger of losing
which is how do we build an ethos of the
open web of the things we believe that
really is in the hearts of you know most
or all of the people that it touches so
that it shapes who they are who their
children are what we build into the
future 10 years 20 years 30 years 50
years so that's the theme I want to talk
about is the ethos of the open web where
there been some victories that Mozilla
has been involved in where we are now
which is I think we're losing and you
know how do we turn that around but I
want to start a little bit with two sub
themes that are really important to me
one is heroes and who are the heroes
that we look to and certainly in punk
rock it was people like The Clash and
the Sex Pistols and the Dead Kennedys
you always need or benefit from heroes
who kind of draw you and embody that
ethos so I talked a little bit about
heroes in the young web I also want to
talk about Lego which to me you know the
Internet at its best it's just a big kid
a Lego so it's for me a good way to
think about what the open web is so
we'll start with a little bit of a movie
teaser on the theory that the theme of
heroes and Lego and if you haven't seen
the lego movie and you don't want to
spoiler leave now
nothing's gonna stop me now this is the
evil guide there's a prophecy yes
suppose a missing piece of resistance
that can somehow magically disarm the
kragle give me a break
carried away one day a talented lass law
fellow a special one with face of yellow
will make the piece of resistance found
from its hiding refuge underground and
with a noble army at the helm this
masterbuilder will thwart the kragle and
save the realm and be the greatest most
interesting most important person of all
so so what's happened here is mr.
business you know who has taken the
kragle the evil weapon that he is going
to use to take control over the whole
world of Lego and you know we've heard
that there is a hero coming if we can
just wait the hero will lead the
resistance and you know for me I had the
opportunity about five years ago to go
and become executive director of Mozilla
Foundation really help reboot what we
were doing and it went because those
were my heroes the people who had
founded Mozilla well before me and
started at John said in the late 90s
became a foundation in 2003 and they had
an ethos that drew me although I think
it's an ethos that we have done a very
poor job all of us but Mozilla included
of explaining to the world the two
billion people on the web don't know
what the open Internet is the closest I
have gotten before is you know there's
two things and we often talk about
openness in terms of interoperability
and and ten principles and all of this
stuff that we you know the kind of
language we use here but to me the test
of whether we're getting where we're
going the ethos I believe in is it an
Internet where anyone can make anything
and where anyone can share with anyone
and to make anything is that Lego piece
of it that HTML CSS JavaScript without
asking anybody's permission you can make
what you want and it's very open-ended
the share with anyone is an open network
that anyone can get anything across and
when Mozilla started as a foundation in
2003 that was not the internet we were
trending towards Microsoft had a
monopoly on how people saw the Internet
it was 99% of the browser market they
were taking that Lego set and moving it
towards ActiveX moving it away from a
standard implementation of HTML the open
Internet the Lego set was under threat
and this group of people who are
actually still in many ways consider my
heroes you know we have to work with
them every day
the founders really of the Firefox era
of the Mozilla project said we're only
ten people we've got thousands of
volunteers sure let's take on the
biggest company in the world because we
actually see the web as being under
threat and they did an amazing thing
they did you know something nobody
thought was possible a nonprofit that
took on the most dominant software
company in the world at its own game and
built a set of values into a product
that then went on to take 25% of market
share and that vision of Firefox is very
particular to I think something we can
be proud of as Mozilla be grateful for
as as people who care about the open web
but should understand and see how we can
seize again in the future which is they
didn't just go and say you know
Microsoft is bad or try to change policy
although I do think the antitrust case
against Microsoft was important in this
story they said let's build our values
into the way people use the internet
every day and let's do that with a piece
of software people want that has you
know trivial things but things that
people desire like pop-up blocking and
better security and then let's get that
in the hands of hundreds of millions of
people and that's what they were able to
do and not only do for Firefox but they
brought web standards across from
Firefox into Chrome into Safari into
even where now seems trivial but you can
basically run advanced software across
any platform and not worry what kind of
computer you're on and that's because
the open area at once
and it's because you know the the folks
who made Firefox did play an important
role I think as heroes in that way and
the you know the result is the Internet
we all know and love today YouTube Gmail
all of those things were not possible
and tell the web standards that underlie
things like Ajax you know became
commonplace on our computers but the
thing is with that victory behind us
it's not actually necessarily the case
that things are going well the companies
that now own large percentage the most
of the Internet traffic that benefited
from that themselves for business
reasons start to wonder whether that
open ethos to make anything share
anywhere you know actually works for
them or not and so we're actually at a
different moment in the lego movie right
now so let's pause and look at that you
bad cop that keeps messing up my plans
people everywhere are always messing
with my stuff
but I have a way to fix that a way to
keep things exactly I'll come back
permanently behold the most powerful
weapon of all the Redax
Oh
oh good movie
you haven't seen to go see it so you
know that I met kids were 12 and 14 who
I saw that movie with and loved it and
they loved the web as it is today and
you know they're youtubers they both
publish YouTube videos they love things
like zoella and Tyler Oakley who are two
famous vloggers for them the Internet is
awesome
and you know it is a creative outlet
that is unlike anything I grew up with
in the television era and in many ways
there's so much still to celebrate from
the victories that have come and the
things of the web has unfolded but you
know at the same time if you think about
the big tension like pre praised Krazy
Glue in the lego movie it is between the
construction set mentality and the open
ended box of Lego and we really have in
many ways moved into the construction
set era yes you can put things on
Facebook yes you can put things on
Instagram but in a very prescribed way
and that may be good or maybe bad and
there's a lot of freedom and Wonder in
that but also a lot of constraint and
constraint that you know as Rebecca
talked about this morning is a set of
small set of sovereigns of the internet
who decide how that's gonna work maybe
care maybe you don't but it is very
different than the open Internet where
anyone can make anything and share with
anyone the things you can make a
prescribe and how they move around is
increasingly limited siloed and also
prescribed but at the same time if we
kind of take the health of our ESO ethos
do a health check on it governments are
also screwing with that ethos whether
that is China or other places that are
trying to block or America or other
places they're trying to surveil
governments are screwing the Internet in
ways that aren't palpable and widely
understood that we all feel and
certainly as people who stand for that
ethos that open ethos you know feel
under threat companies are doing the
same thing and we are in but I think is
actually an exciting fight around net
neutrality in the u.s. this summer
and I think more more important the way
that mobile phones define how we see the
Internet is really undermining virtually
erasing that ethos and just you know one
thought on that that often we don't
consider for the next three billion
people who come online we're gonna be
about five billion people online within
the next ten years this will be their
only computer and this is primarily a
content consumption device or a
one-to-one communication device so
imagine if that was your only computer
and then imagine if that was the only
computer of most people on the Internet
and imagine if that set their
expectations of what was possible that
is very much the Lego Construction Set
reality not the open ethos of the
Internet and that you know just to
underline that the thing that we really
haven't paid attention to is we've gone
from the most democratic distribution
system for information ever the URL
where anyone can make anything anyone
can distribute to anyone - now some a
situation where two companies control
all the software distribution that will
go to the next three billion people who
get on the internet and increasingly
control a media distribution so we've
gone from the most open distribution
system in the history of humanity to the
most lockdown and we've loved it and
that's where we are so that plus china
plus you know the the black and white
YouTube
I don't feel awesome about the ethos of
the open Internet surviving not because
there's not a lot of good stuff we're
doing because the people who come online
in the next ten years just won't know
what it is it'll just fade off into
history and I don't want that to happen
and so the question is where are the
heroes and how do we find them which I
think will be the subject of our talk
but to get us there
one last clip ruining the end of the
lego movie for you
I know things seem kinda bad right now
but there is a way out of this this is
Emmett and he was just like all of you a
face in the crowd following the same
instructions that's you he was so good
at fitting in no one ever saw him and I
owe you an apology because I used to
look down on people like that I used to
think they were followers with no ideas
because it turns out Emmett had great
ideas and even though they seemed weird
and kind of pointless they actually came
closer than anyone else to saving the
universe and now we have to finish what
he started by making whatever weird
thing pops into our heads all of you
have the ability inside of you to be a
groundbreaker and I mean literally break
the ground build things only you can
build defend yourself we need to fight
back against and so the message may seem
trite and obvious that in all of us and
everyone around us are the heroes and
that's the theme of this movie that we
do need to pick up the pieces of the
Lego and build the reality we want and
in doing that they face away the evil
bad crazy glue machines with cool weird
spaceships that they build which all of
us can clearly do with HTML CSS and
JavaScript but the you know that the
message is important in that the the
solution or the way to take the ethos
that I believe in and I believe many of
you believe in and make it pervasive
make it something that lasts for decades
or centuries inside of our hearts and in
the way we shape what our sight side to
be comes comes from people picking up
and building and this is a group of
people who are doing that whether we're
working on net neutrality policy trying
to build an open phone operating system
as Mozilla is trying to teach people to
code all those things matter and
that's what that scene is about and
we're all doing those things and we're
all failing still and that's the
question that I want to engage with here
is it actually isn't in this room
certainly that we're gonna get to enough
weight to protect and grow and deepen
the ethos of the open Internet and it's
certainly not in that next 3 billion
people that will be able to have an
impact we have to look at how do we
actually encourage a next generation of
leaders people who are going to be able
to carry that ethos forward and that's
the thing I don't know how to do because
my kids they love just being youtubers
and so I guess my question is for my
kids the youtubers or for the farmer
John mentioned like how do we build the
next I would say 2 3 5 10 million people
who carry forth the ethos of the open
Internet and that's our question for
today right and I'm mark I'm glad that
you brought up the next generation
because I know you're talking about your
kids and toddlers and babies that aren't
even born yet but the truth is that but
Sheamus is actually a poster child for
somebody who went from passive consumer
in your high school days probably to now
a fighter for the open Internet talk a
little bit about what you're doing now
but more importantly I'm interested in
how you got from high school guy chasing
girls - he - - I was - the co-founder of
open Gulf aound ation well like any
red-blooded American man I I got into
this for girls and rock music and I'm
not joking
I used the internet a lot in high school
instant messenger that was how I picked
up my ladies and gents
so mark mark talked about punk rock I
got into this through my heroes Jerry
Garcia and Trey Anastasio Grateful Dead
and fish we started off trading music
right actual mail trading so I would
burn CDs of shows that I had I'd send
them off
male to some guy he would send some new
shows back to me and we would form that
relationship and then dial up turned to
DSL and we didn't have to do that
anymore
we could just send those shows or didn't
even need to engage we could download
them right online and I found this
community and this community came
together on the Internet
I didn't care about how it happened just
that it did just that I could get my
shows and add to my grunt collection and
then as I got older I would go to
concerts and I would meet friends who I
only knew via the internet or through
mail-order trading they were making lot
art and fan shirts and expressing
themselves however they wanted and then
turning around and selling that stuff
online direct one-to-one relationships
that freedom that sense of it's better
together was how I got into all of this
and that grew up until I was working in
Congress still a huge deadhead still a
huge fish fan and then this whole SOPA
and PIPA thing happened and when that
popped up that was when I became a real
fighter I was a passive consumer until
that moment because at that point I said
what I enjoyed as a young man instant
messaging late at night with girls or
trading or downloading shows that I
wanted from the Grateful Dead or fish
that's not going to be around anymore if
we let Congress muck it up so I embraced
those open web principles but I came at
it from a non-technical background and I
didn't really even care about the open
web principles I cared about getting the
music or getting the girl and that's how
the open gov foundation really started
so mark shermin what are you hearing
there and what Seamus describes as a
pretty organic story and coming to this
ethos that you're talking about that
could actually be practically applied to
a bigger population of other passive
consumers out there well I you know
first of all I don't think you're quite
a passive consumer you know you were
sharing shows and I think that's a key
piece of it is really how do we feel the
internet and what do we expect from it
right you expected to be able to trade
music whether there is legal or not you
expected the system to do that and
survey was somebody was actually going
to change that set of expectations I
break the system
so I think one of the things is how do
we design and build products on the
internet where the things people want
build that set of expectations and I
think that's really one of the reasons
I'm so focused or we're so focused on
phones right now is we aren't building
those expectations right you know you
don't have the expectation necessarily
that you can share music in the same way
on a mobile device so you know one thing
is you probably cared about it more than
more than you say it was easily
activated because it was gonna be taken
away yeah and we're obviously talking to
a room of friends right you're
essentially preaching to the choir all
of us tend to care about these issues
and seem fairly knowledgeable about them
but just a few weeks ago since we're in
the middle of a net neutrality debate
right now just a few weeks ago my friend
and yours John Oliver made a really
salient point which we're gonna put up
on the screen for you that sort of
speaks to one of the big challenges of
communicating this issue today the only
two was the promise more boredom in the
English language are featuring sting
talk about it is somehow even worse as
anticipated the notice proposes to
ground the net neutrality rules in
section 706 of the Telecommunications
Act of 1996 oh my god that is the most
boring thing I've ever seen that is even
boring by c-span standards I would
rather read a book by Thomas Friedman
than sit through that listen to a pair
of Dockers tell me about the weird dream
it had so for those of you who didn't
get to see the full 13 minute rant John
Oliver made it went on his show last
week tonight and talked about net
neutrality for 13 minutes he renamed it
into something that was a little bit
more palatable for consumers to kind of
get and the next I guess overnight in
the next day users crashed the FCC's
open commenting servers to try and
preserve net neutrality regulations and
so what happened there was really
fascinating in that it was really boring
and yet somehow he was able to galvanize
the public so I guess my question is do
y'all have a branding problem I mean is
this something that just the people in
this room and the people on K Street and
Sand Hill Road care about as Michael
manases said again and again I think we
do absolutely and it's it goes back to
my getting the girl or get in the show
how I got that didn't matter and we all
in this room because of who we are and
where we are I think we like to talk
about that sort of how the information
travels from point A to point B and
focus less on what that information is
whereas most consumers of our products
and most of our users only care about
what's getting there from point A to
point B and on top of that even some of
the language that we've heard over and
over and over again today puts off
people and actually scares them open
source open source open data open
networks we've done a lot of focus
groups dial testing large sample surveys
with average everyday Americans those
words actually paradoxically make them
less likely to trust our products and
use our products because when they hear
open they hear hackable they hear
viruses can get in my data can get out
anybody can go in that's a real problem
because if you're stuck at that level
how do you get them to support the open
Internet principles that we all want to
if all you're talking about are those
words that can be scary so how do you
solve for that well I think you know it
is a branding problem and you know we
need something like DIY that you know I
see me in it and I want to be connected
to that brand but I think we also have a
you know it's a strategy or a gameplan
problem that we need to solve and it is
actually where we need to solve for it
which is we tend as lots of progressive
movements actually historically have to
play defense and not offense and I think
that the real lesson what attracted me
to Mozilla in the beginning what is this
offense play which is let's give people
something they want and then in giving
them something they want build those
values build the opportunity build the
expectation
into that so I think you know partly we
need to solve it I mean maybe there's
Peters here and we can get some branding
help but you know beyond the branding
problem I think we need to look at how
do we play offense one of the things
that had heard kind of bandied around I
guess coming out of PDF is imaginating
you know the web is actually something
people do love and do want cable
companies are not the people that that
most folks love the most so you know one
interesting off offense play that ties
to branding is team web versus team
cable in you know how we go after this
is there is a deep emotional positive
association with our lives online let's
play offense on that as opposed to you
know try and actually shut down and play
defense against the bad guys yeah I mean
the the pew pew polls I think are
perfect if you look at how it tracks
over time the internet is the hardest
thing for people to give up when they're
asked if you had to give up Internet
telephone TV your car internet was at
the top I mean I think we there is
something there we can build off of but
I don't think we're building off of it
yet it's amazing as a Torontonian that
was the one thing they let rob4 keep
when he went into rehab wouldn't give it
up and his Crocs so but if I'm a
consumer and I'm getting my Netflix and
I'm able to binge watch my orange is the
new black or whatever it is then what
difference does it make to me who owns
the pipes I mean or if Netflix is paying
a little extra to get that faster to me
so long as I'm getting it and I'm not
having like long buffering times I think
that that's the the problem is we're
trying to like solve it on logic like
that as opposed to be in a much more
emotional level which is to say you know
the brand's you love the thing you love
which is Netflix which is Mozilla which
is whoever like are under threat in some
abstract visceral way that you connect
with emotionally and the brands you hate
are you know trying to use government
graft and bad politics to get some
advantage for themselves I think that
getting people to
understand the pipes is actually not
going to be the winning strategy I think
that's what we've tried to do for too
many years least in a short term I think
in the long term there is a piece about
treating understanding the digital world
as being as essential as learning to
read learning the right learning math
that if you actually want in the long
run to build out of this ethos people
need to understand to some degree how do
this stuff works not so you can play net
neutrality debates but so they actually
can have control over their lives so on
the digital literacy point that's really
interesting because we have policymakers
that are making a lot of these decisions
about setting a general sort of
framework for our ethos in Congress and
even when it comes to school board
setting curriculum for what our kids are
learning and so Seamus has somebody who
was working in Congress co-founded your
foundation with congressman Issa talk a
little bit about sort of the digital
literacy component when it comes to
policy makers what's sort of at risk
here when our lawmakers don't understand
the difference between a DM and and a
tweet as we famously saw with Anthony
Weiner if I had a if I had a desk I
would put my head down onto it no we all
know that government doesn't get a lot
of what we're talking about elected
official staff well the staff the
younger staff absolutely do and I think
that Bill Hunt one of my colleagues back
here bill raise your hand no raise your
hand though he's great at when we when
we build our software when we talk to
people as getting at those staffers who
are younger it's all about making their
lives more efficient easier more social
more collaborative all of those values
those buzzwords that we love but
treating them like users so often folks
in the open Internet world approach
policymakers and approach staff in a
default adversarial role with good
reason but don't treat them like you
would treat other users elsewhere with
the support with the patience with the
human centered design I want to help you
get your job done and make your life a
little bit easier I think that's a huge
huge huge missing component
that does go a long way and I know
there's some folks in this war in this
room that were very successful lobbying
against SOPA Evan Greer is he in here
there you are
I watched your messaging change you and
Tiffany over time from when Sobel landed
- when my mom was able to say I don't
want SOPA and it was when you seized on
the Bieber stuff yeah you take you take
away my ability to see Justin Bieber
movies or videos or songs he's singing
on the Internet
what the hell no way once you got to
that point that was the tipping point
but it was when we stopped talking about
the pipes and it's the same thing with
policymakers when you talk about do it
this way your bills will get past your
constituents will be happier those are
the outcomes that they want and we can
match those pretty easily and I think
we're pretty close and I think that is
the offense versus defense exactly not
offense versus but offense and you know
we need to build we need to fight and I
think we often go at this just with
fight we promised that you all would be
involved in a lot of this conversation
and so John Bracken is our Mike runner
today our esteemed Mike runner and then
if I know a few of you kind of want to
challenge the very notion of what we're
talking about today so why don't we
start with Waldo and go from there
actually a security could you tell
everyone who you are survive - Paul -
Jake with I'm the director of the US
Open Data Institute a night back
Organization for which I'm very grateful
so I would like to hear the other side
of the net neutrality argument guys like
Dave Harbor and organizations like the
CWA what their Communications Workers
America the Union they oppose net
neutrality
there are I've heard some very good
arguments on the other side and it seems
more like a difference of philosophy I
would like to hear either of y'all make
a persuasive case against net neutrality
because there isn't one to be made and
I'd like to get more I wonder which one
to make so you actually want us to to do
that or we want to get more questions
first as I guess you know my my next
my quick one which would be different
than the CWA s I mean I would actually
argue that yes the CWA has a different
philosophy because they come from a
different time when we had a very
different and I would argue worse
communication system and they have a
vested economic interest in it but that
aside I think there are some good
arguments and I think we will actually
see multiple Internet's emerge and we
have a question of how do we keep meta
neutrality for the purposes of free
expression for the having open markets
all of the things that an open network
lets you do and at the same time have
the choice to opt out and have our own
security and privacy and so there was a
project that was going on that Harlow
has told me about yesterday at the open
news hack weekend which was about
offline mesh oriented networks where we
really just want to be able to talk to
each other because we don't want to be
surveilled at all we really want to be
completely off the main network
infrastructure so it you know I that's
my one argument I would make in favor of
having multiple Internet's which does
then break net neutrality
I think there's others you know that say
Facebook would make in zero-rating data
in Africa that said is you're gonna give
people more access because we're giving
preferential traffic to somebody like
Facebook I think there's lots of
arguments that can be made in favor it
in the end
I do think that the democracy and the
open markets that the Internet can
enable are so important that those the
open network argument is the one that
has to win I mean I would agree with
that and I would only add to that is the
the notion of competition is we're
talking we're talking here about really
two providers if you go in who had
dial-up internet did everybody have
dial-up internet at some point right
okay you remember how those prices went
down you started off you got that AOL
600 minute CD that's all you the
internet that you got this month as
Internet service providers through
dial-up expand
then you got unlimited internet and so
you had competition where something like
free markets would work right now we're
talking about Comcast Verizon mostly so
two big guys is that true competition so
even it with net neutrality rules do you
really have the competition that we all
think and are you gonna get the benefits
of the competition with only two
providers I don't think so all right hi
David Ryan from Arizona State University
so we've talked about the ambiguity of
explaining the pipes but another piece
that I think is ambiguous for a lot of
people is that companies that haven't
been created yet could not exist because
of net neutrality but I think that's an
easier one to explain so that's hoping
you might touch on that and and how we
might go forward with that
so unborn companies that are under
threat if net neutrality isn't
maintained as well maybe I'll take it
for a second which is that I mean a key
piece in my sort of open definition to
make anything be able to share with
anyone is inherently about not needing
to ask permission and so you know there
being a level playing field in terms of
who can do what and not having to ask
whether or not I can do it and certainly
you know the whether you like Facebook
or not we wouldn't have had Facebook if
Zuckerberg had had asked Harvard he
wanted to set it up we wouldn't have
Mozilla if we'd had to ask Microsoft
whether people could install Firefox on
Windows and you know the permissionless
innovation environment a level playing
field for that is absolutely key to most
of the things that we actually do love
about the Internet
I guess and maybe this is another
argument against net neutrality I think
there are bigger threats to the unborn
companies and so I do think we want
innovations whether their companies or
activists or whoever to be able to get
out there to the world that asking
permission but frankly the smartphone
operating systems are far far bigger
friction and barrier especially when
we're talking about the next three
billion Internet you
users for those unborn companies than
net neutrality is likely to be and this
kind of gets back at my earlier question
though so if my reality is shaped by the
parameters set by Google or Apple and
that's just the way I understand my
interaction with the web just as you
know my we have a Chinese national who
takes care of my daughter she didn't
realize that she was sent her censored
when we kind of had these conversations
her reality was what it was and so if if
my sort of understanding of where I can
build and how I can build is shaped by
whatever parameters were already set for
me what difference would it make to me
when I'm not even sort of aware of it
I mean I think ultimately that tricky
question but I think that is where the
role of getting out there and actually
building services that have that open
Internet ethos in them that that person
may get in their hand and that's why
we're trying to despite all likelihood
of failure the old Firefox OS and get it
out into emerging markets where people
are getting their first smartphone is so
that they have you know they have a
computer in their hand that works like a
computer that if I write an app that's
just for the three of us because it's
easy to make an app on the device I
could text it to you I don't have to
send it through Mozilla I don't have to
send it through Google right so if we
start to build products that build in
those expectations that's you know
that's how we win with that person so
there has to be kind of a compare
contrast we have and we have to compete
with a different set of value
propositions that build in the values we
care about it's interesting I think what
we're all seeking here is almost a new
Renaissance we had it started in 1997
with the the heroes of which you are one
I'm not I just work for them oh don't
sell yourself short
um but a new renaissance well how did
the last Renaissance start it was the
rediscovery and the redistribution of a
poem a beautiful poem by Lucretia scald
de rerum Natura or on the nature of
things and pick up girls this ed know
anything's gonna work
hey baby are you into the open Internet
that's how I do it
but what what sparked the Renaissance
there was a complete
mind blown the entire western
hemispheres mind collectively was blown
because this poem beautiful beautiful
Latin that's what attracted people but
it showed an entire new universe to
folks who had been inside of a box for
the whole Middle Ages and it was a
simple poem that everybody copied reread
read to one another that even even if
they didn't like it it still showed a
completely different world view from
what was accepted and what we're talking
about here is a completely different
world view than the one that is accepted
I don't know how we got there and I
don't know what are on the nature of
things will be but I think that there
are some folks in this room we're
actually starting to write that share it
and spread it online but I think that
the the worry is we actually have felt
that in the tens or hundreds of millions
of people that new world but as the
number of people who come online and
experience different kinds of different
visions of the internet don't experience
that that poem may just you know fall
away into the sands of history all right
we got a question from the back all
right hello my name is LaToya Peterson
and I had a question for the panel but
first I kind of undirected on the
back-channel there's a very interesting
conversation going on about sex and
gender and kind of a second conversation
that's happening outside of the panel
that's really intriguing notice that
photo in your slide your your slide
presentation that there was one female
in the group of these original punk
rockers at Mozilla and so I wanted to
ask you about how do you thought about
inclusiveness but Latoya you go first oh
thank you speaking of punk so I'm from
DC and we have two very thank you and we
have two different scenes right you have
the punk rock scene but we also have the
go-go scene yeah right I'm representing
cool disco Dan today but you know there
are many other reasons with this and I
think that the overall conversation
we're having about cultural context and
getting people understand really
requires us to figure out how to open up
right and so in DC there's definitely
there were punk kids and there were gogo
kids but there was also a lot of respect
there were a lot of things in common so
just because we didn't necessarily rock
to the same music and sometimes we did
some
we didn't it didn't mean that we
couldn't have similar values in common
is something out of nothing
DIY resisting gentrification a lot of
the things that are in both movements
are very similar about caring about
people caring about spaces beyond
commercialism right but I think
sometimes particularly with open web
activism we can get really really
insular and really closed and assume
that everybody knows the things we're
talking about assume that everyone's a
maker assume that the world hasn't
changed since the 80s and 90s and people
aren't a little bit more responsive to
corporate encroachment than they are so
I think that one of the things I would
like to hear people talk a little bit
more about is how do you broaden the
conversations outside of what you're
most comfortable with and what kind of
outreach in proactive things you do to
try to figure out how do we invite more
people in yeah and I think that's that's
awesome comments and questions and I
think it's not just that this is a
closed group of people and the open web
movement is a very kind of
uni-dimensional group of people and we
need to look at how we broaden that I
think some of the stuff that has started
to emerge a little bit on the edges of a
Ford Foundation in linking the civil
rights movement and the open Internet
movement is some hint at what's possible
I think the other piece is this
conversation at least in this version of
it is tremendously North American in a
place where the Internet is not North
American and the internet that will
matter is not North American and so I
think we do need to solve those
challenges as well and I think I
struggled with in Mozilla is they don't
also as an asset so to a question of
what do we do about it
very very Silicon Valley based
leadership and Verity silicon
valley-based blinders on I think is
something that we really struggle with
but a global community that is
predominantly not North American and how
we actually create space for leadership
of that community to be driving the
direction of Mozilla is I think that I
really try to push sometimes
successfully more often than not
unsuccessfully but I do think it to be
to the point of looking at where is the
next generation leaders look coming from
look way beyond the borders whether
there's this room or this country
are y'all seeing any examples practical
examples where it's working where where
there is collaboration where the global
community is getting better educated
especially in places like China and
Pakistan Turkey where are the art are
they growing leaders therein in an
effective way so I mean I think at very
small wages and stuff we're working on
is we're trying to really grow the
digital literacy part of what we're
doing as a grassroots effort and that's
a place where we're seeing way more
take-up in South Asia than we are and
say well maybe not no more than North
America but like in equal measure and in
ways that are very different and
adaptive and so that's one place I think
we see it inside of ourselves that's one
example we focus on the US so I another
question from hi I'm cool wada wa um
from Stanford but I also ran Wikipedia
for a long time in the mobile side so I
basically spent all my time somewhere
else so I take the more global
perspective but I'm a little pessimistic
obviously you know Firefox OS is kind of
a big push right because for most people
it's mobile or nothing and you guys have
only sold 1 million devices so far so
it's hard to build an ecosystem so I'm
kind of thinking should there be a more
radical approach to you know the open
Internet cuz we don't know if you're
gonna be successful obviously we would
like that to happen but you talk about
didle digital literacy with kids I mean
I'm focused on kids as well but should
we kind of start picking like where our
battles are like concentrate resources
because like what if you don't win you
know you're not viable in a mobile
operating space what are the other
options
the last part in terms of concentrating
resources because my my argument would
be that we need to actually make like
dozens thousands tens of thousands of
different beds like that I actually
think the the likelihood that Firefox OS
as an operating system succeeds is way
less than 50 percent meaning and so I
think you know you do want to look at
ways that everything from encouraging
people to look at digital literacy and
on a massive scale to trying to disrupt
the other mobile operating systems of
which I think there are ways that we may
engage in in that piece of it but I
think part of it is the you know looking
at how we back and encourage people who
have ideas that we haven't thought of
yet I think that's what really you know
nobody knew that Mozilla or Wikipedia or
any of the other things that we think of
as having been successful disruptions
nobody saw this coming in 1994 when we
first got mosaic or 1993 when we first
got mosaic like I actually don't know
all the places to look and it's likely
that the places that will have the
impact and will shape it are you know
not places we know and that's what I
think the previous comment is so
critical is in the next 2-3 years the
next five years in the next 25 years
like we are gonna keep hitting those
walls and unless the ethos we're talking
about is infused in people at an
incredibly diverse set of you know
contacts and I were maybe will win a
little bit now but we're gonna keep
getting screwed so like I can give you
my five strategies but I don't think
that that's actually what matters I
think what matters is how we solve the
problem of really opening up to a much
broader world and a much more diverse
leadership and to that end and this is
for either you know what what are y'all
do what is your foundation what is your
you and what is your foundation and
company doing to try and be more
proactive in reaching out to people of
color women who whose voices and
perspectives you will need to shape the
next five ten hundred years five ten of
the internet yeah yeah yeah I mean I I
think the biggest thing that Mozilla
does is the community piece of it which
is really focused globally on a
tremendous amount of diversity and so
that that part has been in absent flows
a part of who we are and I I feel these
impossible were doing is in the in the
upcycle and so how you actually give
those people like historically Mozilla
has had a governance system which is
separate from the company in the
foundation where volunteers have a fair
bit of decision-making power we really
worked in the last couple
years to build renew a kind of set of
community leaders and decision makers
who are from all parts of the world and
so building that up is I think probably
the most promising effort there are
other things that I think are more
traditional about building diversity
inside the company inside the closer
community in terms of education stuff
that is targeting people who are
underrepresented in our community or in
our company but I and I think that
stuff's important but in the long run I
think that community leadership piece is
that what's gonna pay off and I would
say in the place so one of our products
is is called Madison it's an online
crowd sourcing tool for legislation
policy regulation and it's working
mostly in in local governments DC we got
our DC friend folks back there that's
one of the places that we're working and
when we featured we so we feature
different policy items that are going
through and we kind of have to pick so
when we look at what what we're
featuring what we're trying to get out
to people we're treating everybody all
different colors all different Creed's
all different backgrounds and genders as
user groups and so when we want to get
more users involved in that process will
feature policies that are of interest to
them and that's just a start I mean
we're literally just at the at the early
days of figuring out how to make this
work but we are seeing that that
response and it's not it's not
male/female black/white but it's this
policy is of interest I want to get
online and I want to say something about
it
I want to collaborate on it and we're
seeing almost a perfect mirror of the
cities in which we're working based on
those policy areas so I think that if
you present your your open Internet
principles to everybody where they start
and where they stand and on issues that
they care about
you're almost backdooring in the things
that we're trying to get across and
involve those new communities we have
time for about one more question up
front hi I'm Lisa Ali from ASU and I
work as a part-time web developer as I
was doing my job I found
I have to specify a line of code for
every different processors because of
the different JavaScript implementation
or they only accept certain type of
audio formats or something like that do
you think in a new future that the
mainstream browsers will like work hands
with hands and make the web more open
environment we think that we're always
trying or and I think one of the things
that we really struggle struggle with is
not even a sort of way way to put it and
one of the issues when we talk about
standards is when you've got you know
five browsers four browsers out of there
there's a tension between innovating and
then it means that you're not going to
negotiate in advance how people
implement those standards and truly
becoming standardized where it is the
same I mean like a bold tag across all
the browsers is is the same because
we've had it forever audio formats for
example are something new and so there's
still a lot of negotiation so mostly
it's about how that negotiation happens
I think the one risk I mean especially
in mobile is there have to be incentives
for that alignment to happen and where
what you see is you see the different
browsers going more slowly and getting
to the world of kind of cross-platform
you're talking about where they can keep
some advantage in keeping the standard
fragmented and I think you'll see that
tension for a long time especially in
mobile where you know Google may have
some interest in implementing a bunch of
new Web API standards at the same time
that erodes their Android and a market
share and so you know I think you're
gonna see armwrestling for a long time
all right and before we wrap I want
y'all since we've this is conversation
has kind of careened all over the place
one thing that we didn't get to touch on
that we I just want to hit really
briefly as obviously there is a business
imperative it sounds great to be all
open and have open source but there's a
reason why there's proprietary software
out there that moves fast and when it
comes to development and makes a lot of
money they they have that bottom line
imperative
and so how do you think about sort of
the business part of this in order
because because frankly you know making
money is important in order to in order
for a lot of these companies to succeed
making money is very important very very
important I think Walda actually is one
of one of my sort of load stars on this
issue is that if you make something
that's good enough and provides a
service somebody's going to pay for it
that's not something that at least I
have been in the open source world very
comfortable with to start with but we're
coming up against vendors people who are
working in codification for City laws
for example who that's their their job
they have mouths to feed they've got
employees how do we so we're partnering
with them instead of going to war we're
partnering with them to help them get
better help them get more open and
continue to innovate their industry and
their companies to survive into a world
of an open web and we're getting the
data so we're actually helping them turn
their data to be more open and they're
starting to use our open source software
and then they're using both to turn
around and sell a service to a city so
hopefully it's benefiting their bottom
yeah I mean certainly it even says in
the Mozilla manifesto which stands for
all of this openness that that is in the
context of commerce that we have both an
interest in a public and commercial part
of the internet existing certainly you
know we believe in that but I think at
the very base there are also our core
pieces that we need as a common
predictable level playing field that is
a public resource for all of us I mean
if we think I had a very bizarre
experience if anybody is interested in
US nonprofit tax law you know buy me a
beer and I'll tell you about it but
where I had to fight with the IRS over
whether
protecting the Internet was a charitable
act and you know quietly in the
background over three years and about
half a million dollars in legal fees we
want and the the reason is or the the
the thing we went on is if you go back
to 16th century English law where they
established
you know what is a public good
maintaining the roads was a public good
if I put my money into keeping the roads
open because Commerce because people go
into church is people going to visit
their families whatever you're doing can
travel over them that is providing a
public good and ultimately the Internet
has become so central to our lives that
we need that public good layer we need
the networks to be open we need the
standards and the programming language
is that anyone can use in common and yes
of course you want to be able to make
money and make art and meet girls or do
whatever you want on top of that but the
Internet ultimately has become a must
remain a public good sorry yes I was
FairPoint all right with that our time
is up thank you guys for participating
in this discussion really substantive
stuff thank you guys for all your
thoughts mark Thurmond and Seamus Kraft
thank you